hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one of the topics that's discussed in on
the ends book one by torquatus as the
representative of the epicurean position
is what the Epicureans make of
friendship this was an incredibly
important topic in ancient times just as
much as it is in the present probably
will be for human beings so long as we
are distinctively human and one of the
big worries and indeed criticisms about
the epicurean views on pleasure were its
implications for friendship here's sort
of the worries in a nutshell if what
human beings are fundamentally motivated
by as their final end or greatest good
is pleasure then doesn't that reduce
personal relationships like that
friendship which should involve loving
the other person for their own sake
doesn't that reduce that relationship
down to a matter of pleasure so one of
the concerns would be I don't really
love my friend for who he or she is I
really love them insofar as they have a
capacity to give me pleasure so it seems
more selfish it seems more contingent
when they stop giving me pleasure I will
no longer be friends with them and I
won't make friends with people who might
be deserving of my friendship if I don't
find them pleasant to be around so this
is a very big concern and torquatus says
listen the Epicurean position on this is
pretty clear Epicurus himself by not
only what he said but also by what he
did his own personal example carried out
through the course of his life showed
that it is certainly possible for an
epicurean indeed he is the first
epicurean to have friendships to sustain
friendships and to value them for what
they are
so he says Epicurus pronouncement about
friendship is that if all the means to
happiness that wisdom has devised none
is greater
none more fruitful none more delightful
than friendship
so clearly friendship is at the center
of the good life the life of happiness
as Epicureans conceived of it he goes on
torquatus and says not only did he
commend this by his eloquence but by the
example of his life so what it epicures
do if you don't know
Epicurus gathered his friends around him
and he bought a plot of land which he
called the garden this is why the
epicurean school is called the garden
and he set aside funds and you know made
it a place that would continue on after
his death he even had a will about it he
set things in place so that his friends
would continue to enjoy a life of
pleasure even after he was gone so
clearly by his own example he shows that
friendship is indeed a central value now
he says to return to our subject because
we don't have to look at personal
instances I noticed that Epicureans have
treated this topic of friendship in
three main ways so the first way is to
say that friendship really is in some
respect about pleasure and it's not
disinterested and we do in fact value
our own pleasure more than we do that
the pleasure of our friends but it all
works out because we're rational
creatures and therefore from an
epicurean perspective you know we do in
fact value friendship but it is coming
from an egoistic perspective the second
position says that friendship begins
from that basis but eventually it
changes it transforms into a relation in
which I do value the other person's
outcomes happiness pleasures just as
much as I value my own and the third
position which he doesn't explain quite
as much
is that the Y's have made some sort of
agreement or pact to value each other
and their friendship no less to value
each other's friendship and and and
pleasures no less than they do their own
so he spends more time talking about the
first one and he lays out some typical
epicurean doctrines drawn from in part
at the curious principal doctrines or
sayings so he says there we go this
doctrine that we don't actually desire
our friends pleasure as much as we
desire our own has been thought by some
critics to undermine the very
foundations of friendship why would it
be thought to do so because if I value
my own pleasure more my own outcomes
more my own happiness more then what's
to prevent me from cutting my friend
loose whenever they're not really useful
for me or pleasant to me so there are
some answers to this that the Epicureans
gave you said friendship cannot be
separated from pleasure why a solitary
friendless life must be beset by secret
dangers and alarms what does this mean
when we're by ourselves one of the
things that's bad about being alone is
that we are more vulnerable to whatever
is going to happen to us if we have a
friend they can at least be by our side
when we're going through something
difficult or they might be able to help
and if you think about the nature of
friendships quite often people are
friends with other people who have
skills talents resources that they
themselves do not possess precisely so
that when they need to call on that
person that person will help them out
yeah think about how useful having a
plumber has a friend would be if you own
a house or rent an apartment so he goes
on and he says that's one reason so
reason advises the acquisition of
friends their possession gives you
confidence and a firmly rooted
a winning pleasure he also says just as
hatred jealousy and contempt felt by
other people towards us are hindrances
to pleasure so friendship is the most
trustworthy preserver and also creator
of pleasure for our friends and for
ourselves being in a friendship gives
you a better chance of getting to enjoy
pleasures or if you're already enjoying
pleasures continuing to enjoy them think
about calling up your friends to watch
the game right it's fun to watch the
game if you're into that sort of thing
but it's more fun when you've got
friends to watch it with provided
they're not you know you're taking or
perhaps to invest it in the outcome of
the game but it's a way of assuring
yourself a greater amount of happiness
in this life so he goes on and he says
it enjoy it affords us enjoyment in the
pleasant it affords us enjoyment in the
present and it inspires us with hopes
for the near and distant future so
friendship is about what we actually
have right now but it's also a way of
trying to provide some degree of freedom
from the vulnerabilities that that we
incur and to assure ourselves that we're
going to have some good enjoyment in the
future so that is one key way of
treating friendship it still remains
self-centered but it's self-centered in
a rational way that that realizes that
if you're too self-centered you can't
actually enjoy this greatest good of
friendship so he says we rejoice in our
friends joy as much as our own were
equally pained by their sorrows so the
wise man hears the upshot the wise
person will feel exactly the same
towards his friend as he does towards
himself why because it's rational to do
so and will exert himself as much for
his friends pleasure as he would for his
own so it's a rational thing to do even
though on
a core level we don't actually love the
friend first we love ourselves first and
we desire our own pleasure first to
treat the friend as if the friend is
another self the second point of view is
called by torquatus a little bit less
bold but in a certain respect it goes
even further so he says that these other
Epicureans say that if we hold
friendship to be desirable only for the
pleasure to fords to ourselves it will
be thought it's crippled altogether so
they therefore say the first advances
and overtures that the beginnings of
friendship are in fact self-centered
they have to do with us getting pleasure
so you talked with somebody on the bus
and maybe you're striking up a
friendship it's only going to really be
a friendship if there's some sort of
usefulness to you or some sort of
pleasure coming out of that if not then
you just forget it and you get off the
bus and you never talk to that person
again or until you see them again on the
bus right but with time that sort of
friendship develops into something
different so the people who hold the
second view he says here's here's how it
goes when the progress of engagement or
intercourse here right has led to some
sort of connection or intimacy then the
relationship loss UM's into an affection
strong enough to make us love our
friends for their own sake even though
no practical advantage results from
their friendship so over time because of
the kind of creatures that we are we
develop an affection for the friend for
their own sake not for our own sakes not
for just the pleasures that they afford
us but for the sake of the friend and he
gives examples here he says doesn't
familiarity endear 2's localities cities
playing grounds horses and Hounds
gladiatorial shows fights with wild
beasts you might think in our own time
about the affection that people feel for
the
people who they watch on television or
in streaming video these days or even in
YouTube people they've never met but
they watch them and engage with them
over and over again enough to the point
where they will defend their honor that
get very worked up about you know for
example in Game of Thrones whether
Tyrion is a good guy or a bad guy or
whether you know
Daenerys should have used the dragons in
this way or that way people develop
something like friendship in these sorts
of cases so why not the more so for
people who we actually see face-to-face
people who we engage with day after day
that familiarity doesn't necessarily as
the proverb goes have to breed contempt
it can breed genuine friendship instead
now the third possibility the third way
of talking about friendship that the
Epicureans take here isn't really
sketched out so much and it might to you
resemble the first one so we'll look at
how these might be different what he
says here is the third view is that wise
people the SAP ents those who actually
know those the smart people they make a
kind of compact or agreement or if you
like a pact a equate us in in Latin this
is a sort of agreement that's enforced
in some way to love each other to treat
each other as equals as another self so
he says they've made a kind of compact
to love their friends no less than
themselves and he says we can understand
the possibility of this and we often see
it happen no more effective means to
happiness can be found than such an
agreement or alliance how is this
different than the first way well you
could say that in this case there's some
sort of explicit agreement that is made
almost contract you know in a
contractual manner between the people
engaged in the friendship they lay
things out maybe a bit more informally
than act
be putting it on paper and in this case
it's not so much about an agreement
it's rather what would be rational for
you as a friend to do in relation to
another person so in this case I give
this condition of friendship loving you
just as much as you love me just as much
as as I love myself as a condition of it
and I expect it from you so there's a
reciprocity here in this case there is
not necessarily such an expectation so
there is a difference between these
different positions number one and
number three but in any case these are
three different viewpoints that the
Epicureans did in fact work out as we
find discussed by Cicero trying to
respond to this problem that people were
having with the Epicureans saying that
you people don't really value friendship
as a good you only value pleasure so
you're leaving something fundamentally
important out
you